le coronavirus change les habitudes dans
le golf de dubaï à koweit city en
passant par doha
la peur de la maladie bouleverse les
habitudes les salutations à distance et
les prières à domicile sont désormais de
mise fini pour un temps le shopping dans
les môles ou la chicha entre amis dans
les cafés plus de 3 milliards d'euros
ont été débloqués par la russie les
autorités ont annoncé une série de
mesures pour soutenir l'économie et
lutter contre la propagation du
coronavirus est la ville de moscou a
annoncé aussi la fermeture dès samedi
prochain de toutes les écoles fermeture
jusqu'à nouvel ordre des cafés
restaurants salles de théâtre et de
cinéma au maroc et des mesures
drastiques qui concerne aussi les salles
de sport hammam salle de jeu les souks
les commerces et les locaux de vente de
produits et matières de première
nécessité reste en revanche ouverts tout
premier cas de contamination par le
coronavirus au libéria il s'agit du chef
de l' agence environnementale du pays de
retour de suisse la tanzanie et la
somalie ont aussi enregistré ce lundi
leur première contamination à la maladie
la liste des pays qui ferment leurs
frontières s'allonge
parmi les derniers et à prendre cette
mesure la république tchèque la
slovaquie l'ukraine la russie la bolivie
le paraguay et l'argentine ou encore le
pérou et le venezuela a placé de son
côté sept de ces états dont caracas
alignement quasi totale les habitants
doivent rester confinés chez eux sauf
pour des raisons de première nécessité
toute la suisse est en état d'urgence
jusqu'au 19 avril prochain seuls les
commerces de première nécessité reste
ouvert et genève interdit de son côté
les rassemblements de plus de cinq
personnes
on le rappelle le canton héberge de
nombreuses organisations internationales
dont le siège européen de l'onu
enfin le box-office nord-américain a
enregistré ce week-end ses plus mauvais
résultats depuis vingt ans les salle se
vide par crainte de la propagation du
coronavirus